my guest this week is a 17 year old from
Singapore who makes YouTube videos about
atheism and free speech and is now
paying the price for it
MOC welcome to the Rubin report alright
so first we have to thank the Twitter
warriors for connecting us because I was
trying this weekend Memorial Day weekend
to get off Twitter pretty much but I was
slammed with a zillion people saying
free amos ye you've got to talk to em OC
so for people that know nothing about
you that have never seen your videos
don't know who you are don't know why
I'm talking about you
who the hell is a mosy well I'm becoming
pretty relevant so who the hell well
currently I'm being charged for my anti
religious videos one call it responding
to Tamil [ __ ] of Christians and the
utter call refuting Islam with their own
Quran both of them extremely passed
powerful extremely masterful works
haven't seen any religious videos better
objectively speaking because I've
watched many atheist videos and haven't
seen anything totally objective
I made the greatest anti-christian and
anti-islam video and then so but
unfortunately I made it fortunately or
unfortunately that really depends I made
it in the country called Singapore which
is a complete totalitarian dictatorships
state but fortunately it's not as the
internet so I posted it online and
non-being charge for it yeah okay so
there's a lot there so first off for
people that haven't seen your videos and
truth is I didn't know who you were
until a couple days ago but I have I
have watched your videos now like I do
like them you're you're funny you're
edgy you clearly don't mind putting your
thoughts out there and that's what all
this whole show is about that concept
but you do some intentionally
inflammatory stuff I've seen you licking
a Koran I've seen you humping a Bible
when did you decide that this was the
route you wanted to go when did I decide
that the roof was um okay why did I do
that
well the reason okay I'm gonna use now
somewhat deem
some wood some wood theme now when I use
the phrase somewhat deem is basically my
opinion it's just that I'm gonna use
that phrase now so that I will you know
not be charged for it in st. Paul is
because you know and I use somewhat dim
I'm just stating a fact and they can't
charge me for it hopefully I hope I
don't get track for a show okay some
would deem that Amos did it because
that's funny because people most of the
time on YouTube from the Atheist videos
that I've seen from like you know the
amazing 80s and count of dusty like
those are my favorite guest youtubers
they make points and they do it funny
but they don't go they didn't yeah so
they basically taught me you know the
points of maybe ism but you never do it
in like a completely filthy Frankish
over-the-top funny way before so I want
to do that I want to make something new
like that and nobody ever like condensed
all of those [ __ ] of the Christians
and condensed all the [ __ ] of Islam
and then formed it into one whole video
before and then made it you know just
really easy to see so I wanted to do
that which is why I made those videos
okay so some people who Adeem that's
what you've done I got it so when I got
it wow you you're you should be a lawyer
also I think when when did you decide
you were an atheist cuz you're pretty
young when did I decide I was yeah um
around the time when I was fifteen years
old because there's because I was once a
Catholic and there was this thing called
confirmation you know I I don't even
know what that is anymore but apparently
is this big thing where okay once you
have confirmation then you're I don't
know more of a Catholic or something I'm
not even sure so because of that I have
to think okay what this confirmation
really means what I started to actually
think that topic instead of just
mindlessly going to church every Sunday
which is what I did before so after that
after that so then after that the main
factor was the big turning point was
when I watched the amazing atheist
videos which is what I considered to be
like the second best youtuber all-time
really influential somebody should
nominate her god damn Nobel Prize so
fifteen you you
this confirmation thing you think okay
I'm not into religion but what was the
move from okay I don't believe in it
I have to go ahead and mock it um that
was okay after that confirmation got
enlightened by amazing atheist videos
then okay I was done became an atheist
became cool became rational became
logical I'm a better person I think
after that I went okay after that stuff
happened and I decided I want it to be a
content creator and I decided a school
wasn't for me so I dropped out of school
didn't continue school don't think a
degree is helpful at all and then
continue helping the world with all my
with a bashing religion promoting
philosophy and all that good stuff
because I think you don't have religion
some people some people would deem that
Amos thinks that if you bash religion
exactly what like what that professor of
the Iran is the leader of that Iran
Institute say no religion no faith means
more rationality more logic means more
philosophy more science means better
world and I think it's universally
considered that if you have more
innovation and more you know and
involvement as a human species is
considered good so that's our that's
what I'm working for
go us yeah so would you deem all
religions equally as ridiculous now
obviously I'm guessing you know
Christianity a little bit more because
that's you grew up Christian right but
do you think they're all equally silly
or nonsensical or the lack of truthiness
or any of that yeah
some people would deem that okay
Christianity is I guess in history
because as a longer street that is far
worse and they've done more atrocities
in our modern age Islam is the worst
thing which is why when I bashed now now
Christianity basically got destroyed by
the atheists essentially which is really
great so they don't have as much balls
anymore but Islam you know there's still
people are so scared of them so there I
made the first impact of video right and
and I some people would deem that Amos
[ __ ] them hard in the ass
Buddhism school Buddhism Buddhism isn't
even a religion people missed instrument
thinking as in religion but even a
Buddha himself he said that you know
don't treat us a religion treat us a
philosophy so Buddhism is the better
best religion yeah
it's a philosophy yet so you see the
difference between a religion with dogma
and ideas that you have to believe in
that are improvable and Buddhism which
is more it's more of a spiritual path
it's not necessarily asking you to
believe in things that aren't provable
right I mean I think there's some
element of that I'm not a Buddhist
scholar yeah there's some yeah yeah
there's some elements of it which is
like you know karma and stuff which is
essentially a much more like some people
deem much more fake aspect yes
but yeah yeah that's where it like
becomes really lame the Karma and the
redemption thing that is the stuff which
I don't believe it
but uh but Buddhism they they basically
advocating warm do you like the good
stuff in the philosophy so yeah Buddhism
is the best religion it's not a religion
which is why it's the best yeah all
right so let's let's back up a little
bit so you dropped out of school to
become a youtuber that's pretty much
every kid in America's dream yeah what
what did your parents say how do you
make a dime I mean how do you how are
you living absolutely astounded stunned
wanted to disown me completely discussed
it with me mom kept on arguing me every
day but you know you just gotta have
balls and you just gotta be like I want
to fulfill my dreams and this is
completely idealistic and stupid but I'm
gonna do it and okay it's not stupid
because I think there was an underlying
logic to it and that was like I watched
many videos and I basically I knew the
YouTube landscape and I was like had
ideas in my head and I was like these
ideas are far better than all of them
I'm like I'm like amazing atheist he
makes a completely excellent videos but
I have ideas that are much cooler and my
presentation I can do it far better
actually so I'm like I'm gonna do that
and I'm pretty sure that if I do it long
enough I have a following and I was
right so yeah now I make enough to just
barely survive but uh yeah excellent
so you're surviving on your YouTube Rev
is that right yeah just
leave the accent for now we're gonna
start try starting the patreon yeah
people they want to donate you know just
like to be cool and stuff you know just
I have like my bank account in many of
the videos description I would start off
like a PayPal in patreon but I'm below
18 so do not my accounts though right
there was ones like a crowdfunding and
literally like my PayPal there's like
thousands of dollars inside which I
can't [ __ ] take so jeez disgusting
piece of [ __ ] yeah all right so let's
talk a little bit about what's going on
in Singapore itself because I don't
think people at least in America we
don't talk about Singapore that often I
don't know that people really understand
what the government is or what level of
freedom of speech you have etc etc can
you lay out some of that stuff Singapore
is the worst country in the world in my
opinion it's a completely totalitarian
dictatorship it control the entire
mainstream media and it's and but the
reason why you distinct like Singapore
from North Korea the reason why it's
much worse is because it's way more
insidious people don't know the
atrocities that's happening in Singapore
people and Singapore is really able to
fool all foreigners to think that
Singapore Democratic Singapore is
peaceful and harmonious and they still
come in work with Singapore so as to
increase their goddamn GDP what is that
is that Singapore you know it doesn't
have the kind of like torture where it's
like you know flogging or you know
putting them in concentration camps or
selling human organs but it's more of a
psychological torture where you just
dull the mind you keep them in fear
people you know people usually think
that if you're angry you go out and ride
and protest on the streets but
Singaporeans are angry Singaporeans are
not peaceful but they still but
Singaporeans are not peaceful durang
gris but the government dulls their
minds so [ __ ] bad that they're
basically they don't have any goddamn
passion to do anything so it's basically
it you know it just
manifests itself as depression race
everybody's depressed everybody's for it
[ __ ] disgusting country my country
sucks ribbon so where did you get the
balls to do what you do was that your
mom that just walked by oh yeah yes all
right now I know we have clearance from
mom then so that's good okay no way
she's all into this right
yeah so where'd you get the balls to do
this so if you come from a society with
that level of control and your stuff is
so intentionally over-the-top how did
that moment happen the big guy is
[ __ ] TJ Kurt the amazing atheist he
essentially taught me the importance of
ideas and the importance of thinking
rationally and then okay people might
disagree with you people might say
you're horrible but there's an
importance to do this too you know
give your ideas that will [ __ ] help
out society and and that's what and so
then I just stretched it further because
you know I just spent lots you know fear
is among us even Americans thank god
damn our freedom of speech but they're
still scared that you know Islam is
gonna condemn a knob that which is my D
don't you know you know actually made an
Islam video does ask balls he has mine
the reason why but I felt the importance
doesn't break myself from fear so hours
and hours just thinking I gotta have
balls I gotta have balls I got you
literally just walking around pacing in
my house thinking gotta have balls gotta
have balls and so much balls that even I
mean this I mean the videos that I made
it's it's it's risque even for American
standards the fact that I'm doing it in
Singapore where yeah [ __ ] illegal and
that's a person who is really ahead of
his time sir and very humble very humble
also so that's very important yeah there
you go
all right so tell me about the legal
situation you're in so right now last I
heard you're out on $5,000 bail is that
right dear mom okay so what what were
you actually charged with one um five
charges were for Islam one charge for
bashing Christianity yeah that's
essentially it
yes what's the what's the penalty for
that up to three years in prison
obstetrician yes up to three years in
prison is absolutely horrible then the
main the main ones which I'm gonna get
to like the highest penalties for I mean
like they're all spread out over the
place in terms of like comments for blog
posts and videos and all of that but the
main ones that I'm gonna be charged for
are D Krish it's the greatest anti
Christian video of all time the greatest
Islam
long time but you guys should watch on
YouTube here you beat your laughs yeah
um yeah but some people deem that this
is completely politically motivated
because essentially what the government
did was they check the likened display
because this is essentially mode it's
publicly motive you have to understand
it I was in jail before for mocking the
dictator
Lee Kuan Yew right was already I already
did my time of like 55 days in prison
and they tried to so really I'm like I'm
political threat so do you want to try
to find as many ways to take me down as
possible but the fact is they do not
want to charge me for bashing
politicians because that's frowned upon
by foreigners but right now since
everyone's sucking Islam's dick they
charge me for that thinking that the
mainstream media's and other people
overseas we're not [ __ ] talk about it
which they're right the mainstream media
has not done that because they want to
suck us on stay certain you attack
afterwards so who do you then get to
have a hard luck following the content
producer the goddamn youtubers so yeah
so I might be some kind of idiot for
doing this interview apparently no
you're brilliant Ruben that's the thing
that's why we're on the show thank you
thank you so you were in jail for 55
days
what is so without a children or an
adolescent jail what's it like being in
a jail in Singapore for a kid yeah yeah
he still I mean you're right like you
were and it wasn't you were in with the
general population were you there it's
[ __ ] some people would deem it's [ __ ]
up because they charge me as an adult
even though I'm below 18 I'm not even
sure about that even Amnesty
International who spoke up against Fanta
UN they said I was a child and demanded
the release of me from jail but the
Singapore government being the ruthless
[ __ ] that they are just didn't do it I
was sent to jail and of course it was
absolutely absolutely horrible there are
many times when I even said I wanted to
commit suicide and didn't eat for a
couple of days it's in a cell with a
bunch of goddamn yeah it's a in a Cell
all you have is like
yeah it's just there's a seat there's
there's a CCTV on it you're happy yeah
it's a it's a [ __ ] cell I don't know
I don't know I have to explain it you
don't have the internet you don't
activities all you do just sit in the
[ __ ] cell talking your cell mates if
you're lucky enough you can get some
goddamn books from your parents it's a
[ __ ] cell room it's horrible so I get
the sense that you're really fearless I
mean that's the one thing that's very
clear to me here you've been through
this already you've put your your ass on
the line and you're about to do it again
do you have any fear about any of this
what what could happen to you any fear
OD Anders definitely fear the after you
get going go you overcome it and then
you strategizing find ways to work
around the system and help you know
navigate the area so yeah definitely
there's fear definitely there's anger
and all those negative emotions the
thing is you overcome you overcome those
negative emotions and then after that
you create even more good and big stuff
so yeah that's essentially coming in and
then you create better stuff so did you
ever see V for Vendetta the movie V for
Vendetta yeah when you were saying that
it reminded me of the moment where he
had to break her by putting her in the
cell and then after that she was totally
free that's sort of where I get where
you're coming from yeah exactly you're
totally free and then you know the
system more and then you have more balls
to do even better things I think right
now to try to break me even more you
know they might start to even cane me
with like the goddamn metal strips
it's [ __ ] for about how does it hurt
people lose their fertility because of
that so who knows I think they're gonna
they're gonna do horrible things to me
but uh I don't know if it's bravery in
great intelligence above the time or
just insanity but I'm playing a game
Reuben so keep at it buddy keep at it
yeah I'm with you
so okay so you go to this pretrial thing
a couple days ago and as we said you're
out on the the $5,000 bail what was it
like in court I mean are they saying to
you just stop this and we'll we'll get
rid of the charges like do they want you
just to stop right now or this is
happening no matter what you do
no matter what we do in fact some people
would deem that basically this was all
planned out all along like because what
do I put it because you see that's the
thing they don't want to admit into God
a mainstream media but essentially all
the judges and the judges is linked to
the government and the judge essentially
has to you know tell people tell the
police when to charge me or not they get
to decide basically when to charge me
and when not to charge me so wait oh
yeah before that I didn't explain the
like dislike ratio essentially what the
why it is politically motivated is
because they looked at all if you looked
I basically made a blog post where
essentially I put down the stuff that I
was charged for and stuff that I wasn't
charged for and the stuff that I was
trying for the dislike ratio was
completely huge until logic came along
and asked all those 80s youtubers up
done it now it's much more so maybe they
might drop the charges after that they
won't but yeah the stuff that wasn't
that they didn't charge me for was all
was all it was either the like ratio was
high because it was something popular or
it was mainly like political like there
was one blog post for example when I
made the comment [ __ ] Islam and Allah
doesn't exist I mean they charge me for
saying [ __ ] Allah in one video just one
quote any god damn charged me for that
word so that quote where I talked about
this person called Calvin Chang that
quote should have gotten me charged but
they didn't you know why because that
was a mean quote and and where the guy
was a pap dog pee a piece of people who
run my country a PAP dog who basically
said that the right thing to do to stop
Islam is to kill all of the killers the
ISIS children and that's a bad quote so
if I if they charge me for that it will
raise awareness to that quote and say
why didn't they charge him for that
quote and then it wouldn't make it seem
like it was politically motivated all of
that and they don't want to do that
anymore
well I'm a sly [ __ ]